[Music]
i'm watching the golden globes the other
night okay
what's that i just want to remind people
when it was on a sunday night it was on
uh sunday night yeah that's important
for the story yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it was in hi def um
he's just pointing out that you weren't
in church
channel 4.
so i'm watching the golden globes and uh
and i noticed that you were sitting
behind daniel day-lewis you ended up
getting a lot of screen time i did and
i'm wondering how that happened yeah
yeah that's a great question first of
all can we see the picture here look at
this look at that
and i'm curious how did you manage that
well
i don't know my wife presented
so they invite you so then i'm i get
seated it's a sign seating and i notice
i'm looking at this guy next to me and i
said honey that's dan lewis
daniel daniel day that's dan lewis you
called dana academy award winner dan
lewis
and i said if i'm gonna photo bomb
somebody put it back up put it back up
if i'm gonna photobomb somebody it
better be an academy award winner yeah
because that's a hardcore photo here's
the question did you adjust your seat
well
yes it i'll tell you what i knew it i'll
tell you why my my training took over
now as a good actor when you're in a
scene and the other actor blocks the
lens you adjust and find it
so i found the lens because dan lewis
has got a big daniel day lewis yeah so
what i did is you see is i popped over a
little bit camera right and i found that
lens but i also wanted just one more
time put it put it back up put it back
now your eye is drawn to me
and that is almost impossible to do in a
scene with daniel day lewis only a
chimpanzee or a cute dog can pull focus
from dan lewis and i did it you did it
you did it
an amazing fellow i should have bought
nothing you can't they should have
created a golden globe category during
the golden globes for best
photobomb scene stealing yeah yeah and
handed it right to me for old danny
lewis
that's lincoln